le barbon honnêtement vous êtes chant et
thierry lahaye j'en peux plus tu es fan
de lever le pied mais moi j'en peux plus
alors c'est sa raison sa détresse
j'arrête là j'arrive à courir mais non
mais attends il ya cyril à chaque fois
ont ils fait sortir ça change rien moi
je passe des dossiers tu continues à
faire des va nu suis désolé moi je peux
pas vrai nom mais faut-il en hystérie
j'arrête oui oui sinon il faut quelqu'un
m'aide est ce que quelqu'un peut m'aider
pour thierry moreau mais qui vaut
l'équipe mais j'en sais rien moi mais on
peut retenir pas aidé par jour
oh
alors voilà pascal je suis désolé de
vous je sais que c'est pas très
professionnel de plus présenté
l'émission mais là j'ai craqué je vois
voilà sa mère me l'a confié cyril
hanouna elle a essayé de l'éduquer moi
j'ai chez les ducs à ma façon j'ai
essayé de faire mon rôle de père et il
est indécrottable fait toujours des
mauvaises vannes ne fut pas visiblement
maintenant ça suffit pas est ce que vous
pouvez faire quelque chose pour nous
vois je peux je peux donc oui donc - du
sujet au mas tutoyer d'accord pas quoi
vous êtes amusé à faire des vannes
pourries quand je passais ma vue ça te
fait rire en plus oui je te fait rire
jaune tableau de cloud ça c'est pas peur
n'ont rien fait encore moins que il ya
sûrement être les autres joueurs ça se
voit ça ouais visiblement avec vous si
ça fonctionne je pense que je joue avec
vous oui c'est si j'avais tout le monde
au départ une fois pascal pascal est ce
que tu te fasses que la le moment est
grave est ce que tu peux arrêter la
musique est ce qu'on peut faire quelque
chose pour toi change et de suez qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour l'empêcher de
faire des mauvais zone au moment il a
envie à un moment j'avais une idée je
pense qu'il faut une fois du matériel
déjà donc y mettre du matériel
il faudra la part fait beau car si
l'anglais bien bien vous prêter au jeu
ça vous dérange pas pour les fans un
costaud parce que je sais pas quelle
fortune qu'elle puisse se situe un
simplement tu m'as l'air bien costaud
très peu de puissance je vois ça je vois
ça mais vous est plus orienté vente par
contre nous oui non non c'est dur c'est
dur ça dure alors qu'est-ce qu'il va
donc qu'est ce qui va se passer parce
qu'elle a commenté rénover le but en
fait c'est à tan tan tan calme-toi
l'excité contient pas mais moi je tiens
mais c'est c'est par oak hills et
d'artagnan
c 3po si tu comptes faire mal à
quelqu'un avec ce type de coup de poing
tattoo fois par contacter ban avec tf1
pardon je fais mal mauvaise vanne
d'accord tu fais mal à tout le monde moi
tu fais mal à me fait mal je fais mal à
toutes les télés tu fais mal au public
moi ça me fait mal d'entendre tout ça
j'en peux plus
moi j'en peux plus donc il faut que
t'arrêtes désormais à chaque mauvaise
vanne ce que tu vas faire soit
extérioriser de tout ce qui va pas ça
ce sac là on sera désormais ta façon de
parler tu as fait rebondir les choses
d'accord mais pas ce que je vais vous
parler tu m'as est ce que vous pouvez
montrer comment il faut tabler sur la
clé pied actuellement qu'est ce que tu
veux ben les pieds plutôt c'est pas très
chaud a souffert les pieds non ça et les
mains pardon parce que j'ai pas fait ça
c'est compliqué parce que ses pieds sont
les mains c'est ça donc pour les mains
je te conseille de mettre des gants
d'accord invasif tous les bons si tu
veux un autre chose que les goûts et
saveurs comme ça et autres les gants et
ses affaires une vingtaine d'athlètes au
niveau c'est compliqué ce qu'on va faire
on va faire on va faire un quizz pour
toi thierry la cobas tu peux t'en sortir
je te donne des phrases qui concerne
l'équipe et tu dois aller compléter si
et si tu réponds mal tu tapes d'accord
d'accord tu es prêt thierry oui alors
mais mais mais bien les deux ans et
encore parce qu'elle vous pouvez donner
juste un coin je vais montrer ce qu'ils
voient la fanfare donc se mettre face je
serai vacherot bouclier attend attend la
faute bien l'écouter c'est important
alors j'ai un jeu est un petit peu
dissipée va la préparer
non tout cela je vous paye quoi on
t'arrête tout ça va se passer
d'accord donc simplement un coup de
poing direct mais voilà ça permet
d'extérioriser tout ce que tu as la
caisse qui va pas là c'est autre chose
c'est ce que je vois donc ça ce côté des
hausses et pour ça on va faire un test
donc tu dois compléter la phrase ok ça
concerne gilles les propos de gilles ne
manque jamais de piquant c'est normal
car verdez ça rime avec avec piment
halal est ici si c'est vrai ça passe
c'est pas mal mais peut mieux faire
on essaie de choses non
ça concerne isabelle c'est normal qu'ils
connaissent toujours bien ses dossiers
car c'est elle qui prépare le plus
l'émission oui on peut pas dire mais
isabelle morini bosc mauvaise vanne tu
vas tomber trois doubles et uniques
chaque mois jusqu'à un coup de poing ses
murs dont ceux ci une dernière ah ouais
en 2014 avec les élections municipales
il va se régaler jean-michel la mer non
sans michel aphatie parce qu'il fait pas
la politique lui donc tu tapes trois
fois là tu as toi
et si plutôt que cinq ans qui fait une
mauvaise vanne c'est nous du papillon se
ferait c'est possible aussi ce qu'il
perd deux grands noms sont les grands
mais non est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est bon on peut leur a envoyé à sa
place là je pense que je pense que tu
parles des gants en attendant rennes
s'est invitée pourtant c'est qu'on web
on savait qu'on allait y compris à le
sont pas rassure moi mais j'espère j'ai
confiance en toi et on remercie vraiment
parce qu'à ce matin